Cómo describiría usted como experta de
la situación a nivel contaminación
plástica a nivel global y
particularmente en la región de América
Latina
Bueno a nivel global lo primero es decir
que está la contaminación del plástico
pues tiene origen en las actuaciones del
ser humano y por eso mismo es algo que
se puede controlar es algo que aún
depende de nosotros a nivel global las
situaciones realmente caóticas realmente
alarmante existen estudios de que dicen
por ejemplo que en unas décadas
tendremos más plástico que peces en el
mar hay estudios científicos también que
muestran que ya los plásticos están en
nuestros alimentos e incluso circulan
también en el cuerpo humano es grave la
situación es digamos una Pero también es
una situación frente a la cual se pueden
tomar medidas y justamente el tratado
legalmente vinculante va a abordar ese
tema ahora en América Latina nosotros
Digamos si bien no somos países
productores de plástico porque la
mayoría de los países que producen
plástico están en los países
desarrollados tras Nosotros también en
América la producimos plástico pero no
como otros países pero sí usamos
plástico y adicionalmente somos
receptores de la basura del plástico de
los países desarrollados por ejemplo
México El Salvador y Ecuador han
recibido toneladas por ejemplo en países
como Estados Unidos de basura plástica y
adicionalmente pues en América Latina
además de la de la necesidad de
concientizar más a la población en el
uso y la reducción del plástico en
nuestras legislaciones nacionales
necesitamos avanzar también hacia la
responsabilidad extendida del productor
y es decir que quienes fabrican el
plástico también asuman parte de la
gestión de este de esto que se vuelve
residuos
y aquí dime
por favor no quise interrumpirla
bueno digamos es que hay varios factores
ahí cuando tú me preguntas de la
situación de América Latina y ese es uno
de los puntos que se va a abordar
Precisamente en la negociación que viene
esta semana y es la responsabilidad de
los países desarrollados versus los
países en desarrollo y es que los países
desarrollados asuman el compromiso de
dejar de enviar desechos plásticos o
plásticos cuya gestión es muy difícil a
los países en desarrollo como la mayoría
de los países de América Latina ahí hay
quizás un choque de intereses en algunos
puntos cuales serían las dificultades
para llegar a un acuerdo a nivel global
bueno primero mandar un mensaje
esperanzador y decir que el hecho de que
ya se vaya una segunda Ronda de
negociaciones es un paso importante a
nivel internacional digamos esta Ronda
de negociaciones es una continuación de
una negociación que se hizo el año
pasado en marzo del dos cuando la
asamblea de las Naciones Unidas para el
medio ambiente emite una resolución
Llamando a los estados para negociar
este tratado legalmente vinculante y
este año a partir del 29 de mayo de este
lunes empezamos esta segunda Ronda de
negociaciones y las rondas de
negociaciones Internacionales hay que
verlas con esperanza porque son los
pasos más importantes que dan los
estados en su conjunto hablamos de un
tratado internacional de un convenio que
vincula los estados que es obligatorio y
que va a permitir si se aprueba que los
estados garanticen la protección del
medio ambiente mediante la sustitución
iluminación y gestión sostenible del
plástico ahora también hay que analizar
lo que lo que Santiago me pregunta y es
Cuáles son las dificultades Pues el
primer actor digamos que se opone a este
tipo de negociaciones pues es la
industria la Industria del plástico pues
por obvias razones primero porque es una
industria Pues digamos eh bastante
amplia en todos los países
también quienes comercializan los
productos de plástico y
digamos ahí ahí hay que analizar algo
muy importante y es que
no podemos tampoco decir que se haga una
transición inmediata sin tener en cuenta
que las transiciones deben ser justas
porque la Industria del plástico también
genera empleo y también hay que empezar
que si se va a hacer una transición
hacia la eliminación sustitución y
gestión sostenible pues se tiene que
pensar en ese sector Industrial que
genera empleo también hay que digamos
pensar que Esos trabajadores tengan unos
nuevos empleos